[Musica]
27 maggio 1991 lunedì new york city mi
vedete in cima ad una delle due torri
gemelle in mezzo a quattro dei miei
compagni del college of mouth san
vincent
io mi trovavo a new york per frequentare
un corso di inglese che era regalo di
laurea della mia famiglia e tutti noi
abbiamo delle date cerchiate di rosso
nel calendario della nostra vita
ecco il 27 maggio 1991 è uno dei miei
cerchi rossi io mi stavo divertendo
frequentavo concerti jazz blues vivevo
in mezzo ai ragazzi ragazze di ogni
nazionalità di cultura diversa un
periodo indimenticabile della mia vita
ma nello stesso periodo
io veramente compreso il profondo
significato del termine risorsa scarsa
perché mi mancavano due cose la prima
bere un vero caffè
la seconda parlare finalmente in
italiano oltre ai cinque minuti ogni 15
giorni quando il mio caro papà mi
chiamava nella hall del college per
salutarmi ma soprattutto per verificare
che fosse ancora vivo e quindi io dovevo
trovare un mio connazionale solo che non
conoscevo nessuno a new york in quel
periodo e quindi ho cercato in ogni caso
di attivare le mie relazioni ma eravamo
nel mesozoico digitale non esisteva
internet
il primo sito è nato nell'agosto di
quell'anno e quindi non era semplice per
me trovare un collegamento che non fosse
già parte della mia rete attiva ma io
dovevo per forza trovare un connazionale
e allora con gli strumenti del tempo ho
attivato la mia rete che ha risposto
ed è così che due ore dopo questo scatto
io ho incontrato la persona giusta
mario garraffo mario era allora il
presidente dell'associazione alumni
della mia università nella grande mela
era anche il presidente della
finanziaria del gruppo fiat e negli
stati uniti in quel periodo ed era una
persona però con la quale io non avevo
alcun legame diretto
e ciò nonostante mario mi ha accolto nel
suo ufficio mi ha regalato 40 minuti del
suo tempo preziosissimo ma soprattutto
soprattutto mi ha offerto un caffè degno
di questo nome io io se chiudo gli occhi
ne sento ancora il profumo e il gusto ed
eque la tazza di caffè che ho preso con
mario nel 1991 a new york che mi ha
portato quest'oggi davanti a voi e non è
un caso perché questa è una storia di
relazioni e una storia di networking ed
è una storia di fiducia perché tutto è
avvenuto grazie alla fiducia che mario
ed io abbiamo riposto in questa persona
è che la finta stessa fiducia che la
persona riposto in noi
unendo di fatto due anelli separati
contribuendo da quel giorno a costruire
una catena che ancora ben salda oggi
dopo 30 anni fra dodici giorni esatti e
tutti noi possiamo essere anelli
luminosi che non creano solamente dei
contatti ma che possono costruire
scenari nuovi possono offrire soluzioni
generare opportunità certo se io mi
trovassi oggi a new york
beh allora userei internet per trovare
un collegamento ideale ma per trovare
quello giusto allora dovrei essere
fortunato oppure avere una rete attiva
ma che cos'è che rende una rete attiva
allora beh come in un albero in una rete
deve scorrere la linfa delle relazioni
tutti i giorni e noi per fortuna viviamo
di relazioni centinaia di volte al
giorno da quando iniziamo a fare
colazione al mattino con la nostra
famiglia a quando avviamo gli aspetti
relazionali con il mondo mandando
messaggi inviando email interagendo e
sui social al telefono con i clienti con
i fornitori o con i colleghi alla
macchinetta del caffè in palestra in
piscina in taxi a cena
a centinaia di volte al giorno noi
gestiamo relazioni ma allora tutte
queste relazioni dove finiscono
che fine fanno molte finiscono qui tasto
rubrica quanti contatti abbiamo
centinaia migliaia splendido adesso
prendiamo tutti questi contatti facciamo
questo esercizio e facciamolo anche
spesso e prendiamo questi contatti
mettendoli in una stanza e trasformiamo
questi contatti in persone fisiche reali
allora di quanti noi riusciamo a
visualizzarne i volti quanti volti
effettivamente conosciamo sappiamo chi
sono cosa fanno che esigenze hanno come
possano esserci utili ma soprattutto
come noi possiamo essere aiuto loro
perché lo scopo vero non è riempire le
stanze ma conoscere chi le abita perché
se noi conosciamo chi abita la nostra
stanza e allora sì che siamo parte
integrante di un meraviglioso
ingranaggio che costruisce scenari nuovi
genera opportunità propone soluzioni e
non solamente a noi alle persone a noi
vicine ma in modo sistemico e positivo a
tutte le persone che appartengono a
questo meraviglioso ingranaggio e questo
ingranaggio ha bisogno di essere curato
perché spesso nelle maglie degli
ingranaggi cresce un erbaccia che ha il
grande scopo di incepparli e questa
erbaccia un nome scientifico
opportunismo
e un sano networking va praticato tutti
i giorni non solo nel momento del
bisogno perché se noi non ci impegniamo
a conoscere chi abita la nostra stanza
allora è molto probabile che nelle
stanze degli altri noi si sia un numero
di telefono un'email un volto anonimo e
in ognuno dei tre casi saremmo
irrilevanti e l'essere rilevanti
oggi nel contesto che viviamo ma
soprattutto in quello nel quale ci
approcciamo ad entrare e vitale e lo
dico perchè fino a 15 anni fa il mondo
cambiava in modo lineare con dei trend
che noi riuscivamo a percepire a
studiare ad assimilare e quindi eravamo
in grado di mettere in atto tutti quei
cambiamenti che ci potevano permettere
di migliorare le nostre competenze
personali e professionali e quindi di
rimanere rilevanti nel tempo ma da 15
anni
il mondo sta cambiando ad una velocità
esponenziale
noi spesso siamo immersi in un
cambiamento senza nemmeno percepirlo ed
è ovvio che se non sappiamo dove siamo
difficilmente possiamo immaginare dove
andare e soprattutto come e allora
voglio condividere con voi tre numeri 3
dati che ci possono permettere di
comprendere meglio il contesto il primo
85 milioni sono i posti di lavoro che
verranno assegnati ai robot entro il
2025 secondo una ricerca del world
economic forum fra tre anni e mezzo ma
la stessa ricerca per fortuna ci dice
anche che nello stesso periodo
nasceranno 97 milioni di nuovi posti di
lavoro quindi il saldo è positivo per
fortuna ma sono convinto che nessuno di
noi possa vagamente immaginare che
questi dati non avranno impatto sulle
nostre vite
è uno scenario complesso sicuramente
ma in questi contesti aumentano in modo
esponenziale anche le opportunità che
sono la nostra disposizione e noi
dobbiamo essere allenati accoglierle
quindi abbiamo bisogno di navigatori che
ci possano aiutare a cogliere
tempestivamente proprio i trend e nuovi
perché solamente così noi possiamo
capire quali competenze migliorare sia
personalmente che professionalmente e
quindi rimanere rilevanti non ri ma non
diventare obsoleti e perché questo
avvenga
noi abbiamo a disposizione già oggi
tutti noi un potentissimo navigatore che
è dato dalle nostre reti dalle nostre
relazioni
pensiamoci perché laddove io oggi non
colgo un problema lo può cogliere un mio
contatto e avvisarmi tempestivamente e
viceversa
e laddove un mio contatto non vede
un'opportunità o un ostacolo a sua volta
lo posso aiutare io la mia rete e
viceversa
ed è la potenza di queste reciprocità
che noi dobbiamo proteggere dagli
opportunisti e voglio condividere con
voi un caso che mi è capitato due anni
fa e che sono convinto non sia isolato
sia capitato anche a voi una persona
della mia rete che per semplicità
chiamerò misterix mi ha contattato
perché voleva trasferirsi a los angeles
per avvicinarsi alla sua fidanzata
quindi cercava un posto di lavoro in
quella città e sapendo che io conoscevo
delle persone e mi ha chiesto la
cortesia di entrare in contatto allora
mister xe premetto è una persona
estremamente competente quindi non è
stato per me difficile creare questa
opportunità e in effetti uno dei miei
contati gli ha offerto un colloquio di
lavoro
quindi io quando l'ho saputo ho
tempestivamente ringraziato il mio
contatto americano
da quel giorno è calato il silenzio per
un anno io non ho più saputo nulla
pensavo addirittura che misterix non
avesse superato il colloquio è invece un
anno fa misterix mi ha scritto via
linkedin
con chiedendomi sostanzialmente di
entrare in contatto con altre persone
io era il giorno dell'anniversario del
mio matrimonio quindi ero in altre cose
affaccendati in quei giorni e non sono
stato tempestivo nella risposta
tempestivo invece è stato il mio amico
americano che mi ha chiamato per dirmi
due cose la prima mi comunicava che
misterix aveva lasciato la sua azienda
per tornare in italia cosa che misterix
non mi aveva detto ma poi se essendo un
amico non si è fatto sfuggire
l'occasione di tirarmi le orecchie
perché mi ricordo le testuali parole lui
mi disse gianfranco ma tu insegni a
gestire le relazioni con metodo e ti sei
dimenticato di ringraziarmi per aver
assunto un tuo amico mi ha messo in
difficoltà perché io gli ho detto guarda
non sapevo che l'avessi assunto prima
cosa quindi vedete una cattiva gestione
delle relazioni di misterix stava
rischiando di trasformare un mio gesto
di cortesia in un momento di imbarazzo
di fatto se no io non avessi avuto un
buon rapporto con questo mio amico
americano avrebbe rischiato di bloccare
l'ingranaggio e allora io mi chiedo
perché quando abbiamo un lavoro noi
dimentichiamo di essere anelli portanti
di una catena è la risposta che mi do e
che spesso noi usiamo e uso volete
assolutamente questo verbo noi usiamo le
nostre reti come se fossero dei bei
distributori automatici di opportunità
ai quali avvicinarci solo nel momento
del bisogno
ma noi ci dimentichiamo che i fornitori
di opportunità di questo bellissimo
distributore siamo noi e nessun altro
e questi distributori funzionano con una
sola moneta preziosa una moneta che
richiede tempo va protetta ha bisogno di
cure e anche questa moneta un nome si
chiama la fiducia reciproca
ed è la stessa moneta che sta
pesa per me nel 1991 a new york
e arriviamo al terzo dato 200 che sono
le ore di socializzazione necessaria per
trasformare un primo contatto in una
relazione stabile
questo secondo una ricerca del journal
of social relationships ed un settore vi
sembrano tante se ci pensiamo
attentamente noi ne regaliamo molte ma
molte di più a persone che non ci sono
nemmeno amiche e ce ne accorgiamo quando
cerchiamo di attivare la nostra rete e
scopriamo che la rete non risponde
ed è lì che ci rendiamo conto che non
abbiamo dedicato il giusto tempo a
costruire l'infrastruttura delle
relazioni non abbiamo dedicato il giusto
tempo e la giusta qualità e la giusta
il giusto metodo per gestire
efficacemente le nostre reti ma se noi
gestiamo con metodo le nostre relazioni
e allora possiamo restituire volti alle
persone che abitano la nostra stanza e
tutti insieme possiamo andare oltre i
nostri limiti e qui mi rivolgo proprio a
te perché proprio tu puoi essere
l'anello luminoso della tua catena che
grazie alla tua generosità al tuo
impegno alla tua determinazione alla tua
competenza
puoi aiutare le persone della tua rete
perché ciò che è facile per te può
essere veramente un problema
insormontabile per qualche contatto
della tua rete e magari tu domani anche
tu prenderai un caffè con qualcuno che
tra qualche tempo potrebbe aiutare una
persona a te vicina perché no magari tuo
figlio o tua figlia a realizzare un
proprio desiderio e viceversa per cui
lasciamo scorrere tutti i giorni la
linfa delle relazioni e ritorniamo ad
essere contadini delle nostre reti
perché come dice bene il filosofo dalle
orecchie lunghe non cresce quello che
semini ma cresce quello che in nafi buon
networking a tutti